This was the factored form. Excellent work if you got that one correct. When we
start to factor, we should always ask ourself, is there GCF. Each of these terms
doesn't share an a, but they do share a 5. If we factor out a 5, we're left with
this trinomial. We multiply a times c to get negative 45. And then we put
negative 4 in the bottom, the b term. We want to find factors of a times c that
sum to b. So we want to find factors of negative 45 that sum to negative 4. Here
are factor pairs for negative 45. I made the first factor negative, each of
these sums would be positive so I need to make the second factors negative. 5
and negative 9 sum to negative 4. So this is what I use to rewrite negative 4a.
Remember it's best to put the negative coefficient first. It makes our factoring
more simple. We can factor 3a from the first two terms, and a positive 5 from
the second two terms. Finally we factor out an a minus 3 to give us this
expression. And we don't actually need to include these brackets anymore since
all we have between factors is multiplication. This is the complete factored
form.